Hey Youtubers it's Charlie.
So this week on Game Of Thrones we are going to meet the Sand Snakes for the first time.
They are going to be a little bit different on the show then they are in the books
So what I'm going to do is going to do a break down of their history in the books
And then talk about some of the minor changes the show is making
Just like a lot of other characters that they end up changing from the books what I think is going to happen
is they'll give them story from characters that they cut out.
So just careful for SPOILERS for everything that has happened on the show so far
So in the books there are eight total Sand Snakes.
They're the bastard daughters of Oberyn Martell and various women.
The show is only doing three of them: Obara, Nymeria and Tyene.
On the show Nymeria and Tyene are both the daughters of Ellaria Sand.
That's a big change from the books.
In the books Ellaria is the mother of the four youngest Sand Snakes.
Ones that are really, really young.
They don't get a whole lot of time in the story; they just run arround and play in the Water Gardens.
It's the oldest Sand Snakes that really contribute to the plot.
Obara Sand is the oldest
so on the show she's actually probably one of the least changed characters.
She's still  the daughter of a mystery prostitute.
They never say who.
When she was old enough he came to claim her.
He threw a spear down in the sand and said: "you chose the spear";
which represented a life a life with him;
"or you chose your mother"; and she chose the spear
All eight daughters are bastards, but they all have very different personalities
Obara is the most militaristic
She chose very martial pursuits.
In the book she's arround like Jamie Lannister, Cersei Lannister age.
The show has changed that just because it's aged all the characters up.
Jamie, Cersei Lannister are, you know, nearing their fourties.
Although on the show, based on the actress that they casted,
it seems like she is closer to her thirties, late twenties maybe.
Because Obara is such a warrior she uses a number of weapons
very effectively. Most notably the spear and the whip.
The same tipe of spear that Oberyn Martel used.
But, because the show whants to distinguish the characters
It's giving each of the Sand Snakes that is doing a separate weapon
It is to say it is kind of showcasing different specialties for each of the characters
Which is true to the books too. Each of the Sand Snakes have their own specialties.
But because they are simplifying the characters, just a little bit
we might not see some of those.
Moving down the list is Nymeria Sand, she's like the next
oldest Sand Snake. This actress right here on the show.
Her mother is actually a noble woman from old Volantis.
Remember that was the place where Tyrion just got bogarted by Jorah Mormont.
Oberyn Martel is famous for having sex with, like, half the world, so
She's just more proof that he has children all over the world.
There are a couple big differencies between her and Obara Sand in the books
Nymeria is much more elegant,
more refined, and she uses different weapons.
Obara is like the rough and tumble Sand Snake.
She's just as likely to get into, like, a drunken fist fight.
Nymeria is a little more calculated,
a little more withdrawn.
She's also said to be one of the most beautiful Sand Snakes
You can say that is a matter of opinion on the show
But, Jessica Henwick, very beautiful
In the trailers they have shown her using the whip
you know, whiping the bucket of that person's head that is buried in the sand
In the books she actually uses daggers,
which it looks they have given to Tyene Sand
So you can see how they have given each of the Sand Snakes
their own type of weapon to be awesome with.
Moving further down the list is Tyene Sand
She's the daughter of  Oberyn Martel and a mystery septa.
There's a lot other theories that secretly  she might be a Waynwood
and have some sort of claim on the Eyrie
but, that's just a wild theory that hasn't been debunked yet.
The show isn't going to be doing any of that.
In the context of the books, her mother was a septa near High Garden.
It just talks about her crossing the Mander river
with Oberyn to visit her mother once,
and the Mander runs through the Reach.
On the show it looks like she'll be using daggers a lot
You can say Nymeria is daggers.
Maybe she just borrowed them from her.
In the books she is the expert of poisons that Oberyn Martel was.
So moving down the list to Sand Snake number four.
We're getting into Sand Snakes that the show is not doing.
Sarella Sand is the daughter of Oberyn Martel and
and a woman from the Summer Isles.
So far the show hasn't traveled directly to the Summer Isles.
We might see that in the future tough.
It's way down here, so you can see why we haven't seen it yet.
Most of our time in the show has been spent way further north.
I know a lot of you are really hoping to see the southern continent at some point.
If we do go there, we would definitely see the Summer Isles,
just because it's so close.
Really it just depends on which characters the show is going to do.
So moving down the list, we have the four Sand Snakes
that are the daughters of Ellaria Sand in the books
We're not going to see any of these characters,
because Ellaria Sand they kind of give the Eryan Martel storyline
and made two of the older Sand Snakes her daughters.
So, you can see they have changed a lot of that.
But, in the books the oldest of Ellaria's children
is Elia Sand, named after Oberyn's sister, of course.
She's said to be really fond of horses and jousting.
Imagine a really tiny version of Brienne charging on a horse
There actually is some precedent for some really badass women
in recent memory in Game of Thrones's history.
Lyanna Stark was actually suposed to be a pretty decent fighter.
Remember, she looked like Arya Stark
or Arya Stark looks like her, so
the fact is going to be training with weapons,
kind of pays onto Lyanna's memory,
although Arya never knew her.
The next oldest Sand Snake is Obella,
then Dorea and  Loreza.
All the Sand Snakes in the books and on the TV show are bastards,
but they do have varying degrees od noble blood.
When I say that I mean on their mother's side,
with the exception of maybe Obara Sand
who's mother was a whore.
The show hasn't really explained it a lot
but, Ellaria Sand is actually the bastard daughter
of Lord Harmen Uller.
He's one of the noble houses sworn to house Martel,
just, like, say the Karstarks are sworn to the Starks,
But, it looks like the show might not be doing lord Harmen Uller,
so it might not go into her backstory in that way.
In the books, Harmen actually accompanied Oberyn Martel to King's Landing,
so we would have seen him in season 4 if the show was going to do him.
Here's my big question for you guys:
Which Sand Snake on the TV show are you most looking forward to.
I mean, Obara seems the most badass one,
but because of some of the changes they made it seems they are all going to be badass.
They're like a group of characters that can't help but make a mess of things
at least that's the way they look, so I'd think that they'll be saved to season 6.
I do think that there's going to be a big WTF death in the Dorne storyline,
but I don't think it's going to be any of the Sand Snakes.
It just seems like the characters who allways make a mess of things
have the best chance of surviving, just because they are more interesting.
You could point to Oberyn Martel as someone who makes a mess of things
and he died within the span of a season,
but I feel like the show was just putting him forward as almost being invincible
and that's usually when they pull the rug out from under you.
They made it someone, you know, cackles in, like, comic book vilainy
and seems too invinvible,
usually that's when they are gettin ready to go down.
But you guys can let me know, which character as part of this giant Dorne Storyline,
wherever they might be from,
do you think is going to die before the end of the season.
Based on the number of episodes we have left,
there's only a certain amount of time for them to do, like,  big WTF deaths
Usually by the time we hit episode 4 or 5 each season
it's really when stuff starts going crazy.
Dorne, hands down, I think it's going to be one of the most interesting new places
that the story has gone.
It's just a whole new group of people that we haven't spent 3 or 4 years with already
Fresh meat for the grinder.
So, has we go along this season,
if  there's any specific Dorne or House Martel related story
that you guys want me to do a bonus video for, just let me know.
Don't forget, tonight is a new round of the giveaway
so be shore to subscribe as you get my episode video.
I'll post it after the episode airs.
If you guys heve been using HBO now,
let me know what your experience has been like.
I've actually been using it to watch the season.
It's actually been pretty stable.
It hasn't crashed like HBO go did last year,
so it has actually been really nice.
So, while you guys wait for me to post the episode video tonight,
you can click here for last weeks episode
and you can click here to learn all about the history of Winterfell.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody, lets HIGH FIVE!
I'll see you guys tonight.